now earlier I mentioned what's been
going on in Paris and in France for the
last little bit and what's also been
happening in Germany for quite some time
the Netherlands and some of the other
Western European nations but France has
a particularly bad version of this
because they let in hundreds of
thousands of people most of them legally
but some illegally as well and now these
people are out on the streets they are
rioting they are burning down Paris
you're barely seeing it on the
mainstream media because it doesn't fit
the narrative but this video is going
viral this is a a French immigrant uh
well I'm not even going to color it
anyway this is a French immigrant
talking about why what's happening right
now in Paris is happening
racist
s
France has a problem now I don't want to
make it seem like every immigrant in
France is a believer of what that guy
said but clearly he's saying like the
quiet part out loud to some extent like
oh you did something to our ancestors
way back when now we're here for payback
what's interesting of course is he's
living a western life he's dressed like
a western citizen he's speaking French
right but he's basically saying I'm here
to destroy this country
so putting that aside putting France
aside for a second all I'm saying is
from an American perspective do we have
every right to protect our border and
say hey here are the things we believe
in in this country we believe in
individual rights we believe that women
should be treated fairly we believe that
minorities should be treated fairly in
all of those things so you can't then
bring in a whole bunch of people who
don't believe not only don't believe
those things but that are also a tax on
the system meaning they want social
services and then it's other people who
actually get taxed to pay for their
lifestyle and then you end up in a
really horrific situation like what
France has right now where they're going
to have to decide the average Frenchman
is going and their political Elite are
going to have to decide will we remain
France will we will French culture mean
anything or will we just give it away
that that will be up for the French to
decide but here in America I think we
still have a chance to fix some of this
[Music]